As polished or hilarious as a movie script
might be, it usually pays to let talented
actors flex their muscles in front of the
camera.
Whether it's on-the-spot jokes, or in-the-moment
drama and action, the most memorable movie
moments come when the script is tossed out
the window.
Here are Screen Rant's 20 Greatest Unscripted
Movie Moments.
The Avengers
As witty as writer/director Joss Whedon was
when it came to the script of The Avengers,
Robert Downey, Jr. did him one better.
When the script called for Iron Man to call
Thor "Shakespeare in the Park," Downey got
the idea, delivering one of the movie's biggest
laughs, right off the top of his head
X-Men
Hugh Jackman may have been called in to play
a live-action Wolverine at the last minute,
but he made his mark on the cast immediately.
While filming his first scenes in Xavier mansion,
he decided to take an unscripted shot at Professor
X They
probably knew then that he already had Logan's
characters perfectly formed, - humor and all.
Amazing Spider-Man
There's no limit to Emma Stone's charm, which
means that even when she accidentally calls
her superhero boyfriend by his REAL name the
cameras keep rolling.
She was supposed to say Spider-Man, and her
reaction was completely genuine, but perfect
for the character.
Edge of Tomorrow
There isn't much time for romance when aliens
are slaughtering Tom Cruise day after day,
but when his co-star Emily Blunt decided that
forgetting her line, and just kissing him
instead felt like the right move for the scene,
he was left to react as best he could, with
the cut used in the finished movie
Top Gun
It isn't just Tom Cruise who GETS kissed without
warning, either.
The love scene from Top Gun became famous
before it left theaters, but it started by
accident.
When Cruise and his co-star Kelly McGillis
faced off on the street, he actually just
forgot his line, and kissed her instead - the
perfect way to get to love from hate.
Mr and Mrs Smith
Strange things happen when the same scene
is shot over, and over, and over again.
But when Angelina Jolie had the same Jeopardy
clip drilled into her brain, she couldn't
help but blurt out the answer in between her
lines.
And that's just the kind of random moment
directors can't help but include in the final
cut.
The Matrix
Keanu Reeves put in the work to master martial
arts for his role as The One, with Bruce Lee
an obvious idol.
So when the sparring session allowed he and
Lawrence Fishburne to loosen up, Reeves couldn't
help but throw in Lee's patented nose flick,
even though it wasn't in the script.
Pulp Fiction
When an actor like Samuel L. Jackson decides
to improvise, other actors just try to keep
up.
After delivering his hamburger monologue in
his first Pulp Fiction scene, Jackson decided
to flip a table without warning the actor
sitting at it.
The move was brilliant, and audiences still
get to see the stunned, completely honest
reactions.
Fast & Furious
Brian O'Conner got a rough welcome to Dominic
Toretto's gang, first tangling with his friend
Vince over Dom's sister Mia.
After some rough fight choreography didn't
go as expected, director Rob Cohen told the
actors to just... well, fight.
What you see in the film is a completely improvised
street fight - and it shows.
Guardians of the Galaxy
The first fans saw of Marvel's Guardians of
the Galaxy was the criminals' arrest and line-up,
and the scenes summed up each character pretty
well.
It was Star-Lord's finger cranking that got
the biggest laugh, and was thought up by Pratt
completely on the spot.
Director James Gunn told him to add an apology,
and the bit was complete.
Speed
It's still hard to imagine Keanu Reeve's jump
from Bill and Ted to a certified action star
in Speed, and director Jan de Bont knew that
audiences might not realize the movie's hero
was as smart as he was.
Needing to show that Officer Jack Traven was
thinking through as problem, a pack of gum
became the answer.
Chewing means thinking after all - and it
actually worked.
End of Watch
Nothing shows a vulnerable side to a character
like singing in their car, and in End of Watch,
audiences got to see Jake Gyllenhaal and Anna
Kendrick's characters make a duet of Camron's
"Hey Ma."
But it actually wasn't their characters.
Director David Ayer was in the backseat preparing
to shoot written scenes for the pair, when
they shared the song while getting to know
eachother - with his camera rolling the whole
time.
Titanic
James Cameron knew he had one-of-a-kind stars,
and encouraged Kate Winslet and Leo DiCaprio
to improvise a few times in the film.
The best came when he told Winslet not to
throw a hairpin at actor Billy Zane as planned,
but spit right into his face.
She did it, and Zane's very real reaction
can be seen in the film.
Ghostbusters
There were plenty of comedy legends to choose
from in the first Ghostbusters, but it's Rick
Moranis who comes away as the most underrated.
As the incredibly weird neighbor Louis, the
rambling lines and monologue given while hosting
a party in his apartment was almost completely
improvised, moment by moment.
This is The End
The minds behind the movie claim that almost
the entire shoot was improvised, and it shows.
But the improv didn't actually need much to
get off the ground.
The scene involving the gang getting into
a heated argument over a single Milky Way
bar is 100% unscripted.
Batman
No portrayal will likely match Jack Nicholson's
version of the Joker - a villain so weird,
you can't help but love him.
Most of his lines were in the script, but
Nicholson has admitted that his strange raspberry
blow, flying bird exit from Vicki Vale's apartment
was complete improv, making us wonder where
the script ended, and the real Joker began.
Gladiator
It's hard to forget the opening battle of
Ridley Scott's Roman epic, but both he and
star Russell Crowe knew that a quieter moment
for Maximus was needed before the action started.
The problem was, none had been written.
While trying to come up with a solution, a
bird decided to hop its way through the set.
So Scott rolled the cameras, Crowe gave his
reactions, and the rest is history.
The Lion King
It isn't just live-action actors who get to
improvise, either.
When the time comes for Timon to cause a distraction
to help Simba return to Pride Rock, actor
Nathan Lane decided to add a joke suggestion
of his own It turned out that was a better
idea than what had actually been planned,
meaning Timon wound up doing exactly that.
Alien
Ridley Scott wasn't afraid to use tough love
in getting the best from Sigourney Weaver,
making sure her co-stars really did slap her
instead of faking it.
But to truly put her on edge, he instructed
actor Yaphet Kotto to interrupt all of her
lines.
By the scene following Dallas' death, she'd
had enough, telling her co- star, not the
character to "SHUT UP!"
The Dark Knight Rises
The villain Bane may have been terrifying,
but you can't say he didn't have a sense of
humor - or a softer side But Bane's description
of the young boy singing the national anthem
at a Gotham football game was actually actor
Tom Hardy's, improvised on the spot.
Conclusion
Those are some of our favorite improvised
or unscripted moments in classic movies, but
which ones have we missed?
Let us know in the comments, and remember
to subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one.